e
e e
okay folks
I'm going to I'm going to
start I'm going to start with a question
that's going to become borderline
harassment at this stage which is how
many of you have not picked a company
yet how many of you have not picked a
company okay I'll take that as
everybody's picked a company even though
I know it's not true and we'll keep
moving so if you make sure you're in a
group in a company because next Monday
we have no
class I'm not sure what we're supposed
to do for President's Day it's one of
those freebie Mondays there no
obligation that comes with it so it's
it's a nice holiday because nothing else
needs to get done but this is the time
for you to kind of catch up if you've
fallen behind on the notes or reviewing
the site because now after 40 Years of
teaching these semesters go through a
rhythm you start slow you stay slow and
then all of a sudden things hit boom
right because two weeks after you come
back next week the Monday I think what
is March 3rd is your first quiz so I'm
going to put up a review session this
weekend for those of you who want to get
a jump some of the material will still
be we haven't got there yet but at least
you can start looking at what those
quizzes look like and as we get closer
put a you know you can you can watch the
review session that goes with the with
the review material so as I said every
quiz I've written for this class I think
the very first quiz in the packet might
be from
1986 okay every so it's all out
there and so you have no excuse saying I
don't know what the quiz looks like okay
what will the this quiz look like I
haven't written it yet I'm in the
process of writing it maybe I'll WR I
have a flight tomorrow I'll write it on
the flight and then I have to make sure
I haven't screwed up somewhere in
writing the quiz so that's when we come
back but let's go back to where I left
you off on Monday we were talking about
the capital asset pricing model or the
cap and the number that comes out of it
that we end up using over and over in
finance which is beta so Constantine is
going to get me started today and the
question I have is a very simple one to
get to using betas as a measure of risk
I'm I made a whole host of
assumptions Constantine can you list out
some of the things I had to assume along
the way for me to conclude that beta
measures
risk that's once I get a beta no we've
jump way ahead let's go to the start of
the process to even get to the beta what
was the first step I had to assume that
I lived in a mean variance world right
that all I cared about as an investor
was what's he expected return what's the
standard deviation and we already saw
that that's not quite true because we
want big payoffs we're worried about
losing too much money so as investors
that's not irrational we bring them in
so it's a mean variance framework which
already is a framework that we know is
going to be flawed because human beings
put other things into the decision
process Derek what's the next assumption
I had to
make marinal investors Diversified how
do I get there because essentially if
you have investors out there of a lot of
money over time they're going to be
Diversified and since the margin
investor owns a lot of stock And Trades
a
stock I was going to say you and I but I
don't want to insult you if you're a
billionaire I am never going to be the
mar investment a company maybe you could
if you have three five 10 billion to
play with but it's going to be an
institution usually who's
Diversified so mean variance framework
faulty marginal investors Diversified
that might work in big companies maybe
even midsize companies but you're saying
what if I have a small Indonesian
company I'm doing clearly we're going to
be pushing the limits of that assumption
and if you're doing a privately owned
business the Assumption completely
breaks down mean variance
framework Diversified investor what else
that I have to assume to get to
Beta so investors diversify when do they
stop diversifying in the
C never
why anybody want to help me what are the
two assumptions no transaction ction
cost which includes monitoring cost all
the things you worried about and
secondly none of us can pick the right
stock so what's the point of stopping so
where do we end up we all end up owning
the legendary Market portfolio that
Vanguard market index that includes
every single traded asset in the world
and once you're there you got the cap
because the risk of any company any
investment then will be the risk it adds
to that market portfolio that's what
beta measures with that co-variance
basically by looking at what a stock or
an asset does rela to the market
portfolio you're looking at the risk
added to that market portfolio that's
quite a piling up of assumptions we had
to make to get to betas every time you
use beta you're carrying all that
luggage with
you you might not want to think about it
every single time but it has to be in
the
background and then towards the end of
the class I took a look at what the
limitation of the gapm are starting with
the fact that we make unrealistic
assumptions of course we do moving on to
the fact that beta could be wrong yeah
so could everything else in my analysis
if that stopped me I would never be able
to do any kind of business analysis but
the third critique is the most difficult
one to deal with if beta is a good
measure of
risk and if I look at stocks across very
long time periods clearly in one year or
two years it might not but let's say I
take 50 years of returns across
stocks all of the differences in return
should be explained Away by difference
in high beta stock should earn high
returns low beta stock should earn low
returns and that should hold
right in
1992 two professors the University of
Chicago Ken French and Jee farmer
decided to ask this question how much of
the variation and returns over very long
periods is
explained by ba
what's the number we'd like to see
correlation of 100% one right they found
about 10 to 15% of the variation in
returns in stocks is explained by
Bas put more bluntly we're using a model
that doesn't explain 85% of what's going
on you're saying why would you want to
do
that and people have asked that question
repeatedly over the last 50 years 60
years and they've tried to come up with
other ways of measuring risk that might
work better than the BET beta so I'm
going to take you through a short
history of all of the risk and return
models you will encounter in finance the
capm came out in 1964 for 14 years it
was the only game in town and when
you're the only game in town it's be
easy to be at the competition the capm
ruled in 1978 a professor Adel Steve
Ross said hey you know what I agree
Market risk is the only risk that should
be in the in in the expected return
but the risk in the market comes from
lots of different places from interest
rates from inflation from the
economy why can't we have different
sources of Market risk and have a beta
against each one and when he first came
up with this people said that's nice but
how would we know how many sources of
risk there are and what the bait against
each one is he said that's easy give me
a powerful computer and stock returns
for 50 years for individual stocks and
I'm going to let the put the computer in
a search measure what is it searching
for how do we Define market risk most or
all companies are affected by that risk
this morning we got an example of mar
Market risk what was the big big macro
announcement that came out this morning
inflation inflation is at 3% people are
a little you know and if you look across
the market you're seeing the damage
across the market so what the computer
is looking for is patterns in the stocks
it's called factor analysis it goes to
the data the computer has no economic
intuition it just says let me find 1500
stocks seem to move together I'll call
that factor one factor 2 factor three
looks for how many factor and it came
back and this is the late '70s with the
conclusion there are five
factors that drive stock returns Market
risk factors and here are the Bas
against one this is like a bonan you've
got five factors you got the Bas against
each
one that was the Arbitrage pricing model
it wasn't even an economic model it was
a statistical model built on the premise
that looking at returns would tell you
what the market risk factors were when
it came out people thought this was a
godsent we could replace the capm with
the Arbitrage pricing model but it never
quite caught on and to see
why let's suppose you're a company you
want to use this to come up with your
cost of equity you're
Pepsi Purchase New York I'm your
investment banker I show up in your
office you've been using the capm for
the last 14 years to come up with the
cost of qu let's say it's 11% so we have
a new model it's called the Arbitrage
pricing model I put the numbers in for
Pepsi into this model and you expected
return is
15% first reaction is that sounds a
little high why is our cost of equity so
high and I tell you it's because you're
really sensitive to the second
Factor tell me what's the question
you're going to ask me right after I say
that what the heck is the second factor
and my reaction will be I don't know
what it is but be very careful when it's
around you see why the model never
caught on what business is going to say
I'm going to use a higher cost of equity
because I'm sensitive to the second
factor and I can't tell you what the
second factor is so for lawn I walk home
that's a long way from purchase to New
York City but I have nothing else to do
and while I'm walking home I'm thinking
of why my sales ptch fa failed which is
when you asked me what the second Factor
was I couldn't give you a name for the
next eight years bankers and academics
spend millions of dollars trying to put
names on the factors think what's the
big deal just name them whatever you
want you can't name them randomly you do
know their macroeconomic factors so what
they effectively did was they looked at
the past when the factor analysis come
back comes back to the factors it also
gives you a graph of each factor factor
one looks like this Factor two looks
like this they actually took
macroeconomic factors and tried to fit
them to see which one fit each factor
8 years later they named the
factors when you name the factors you've
gone from an Arbitrage pricing model to
what's generically called a multiactor
model each market risk factor with the B
against each one Victory
right here's the problem multifactor
models I'm back at Pepsi again 8 years
later they say I have a new model you
saw what happened the last time I had a
new model you're a little wary and I say
with this new model your cost of equity
is 18% you said that sounds even higher
than last time why is it so sensitive
because you're really sensitive to the
second Factor but this time I'm ready
for your question I've actually come
prepared to ask myself the question if
you don't ask me what's the second
factor and it say it's oil prices you
say what we don't use oil in Pepsi it
might taste like we do but we don't what
do we have to do with oil prices
how do we fit the factors we Look
Backwards right and one of the things
leading into the 80s is oil pric were a
big factor driving Market risk so you
fit the factors right but you fit them
for the past but by the time you got to
the mid 80s oil prices were no longer a
factor the problem with multifactor
models is you can fit the model really
well for the past but since the factors
are unstable and keep changing coming up
with expected returns is a bit of a
nightmare so that didn't stti then in
1992 Gene farm and Ken French the two
people who discovered that you know B
didn't explain anything said why are we
even trying to build risk and return
models why don't we let the market tell
us what's risky and what's safe how will
the market tell you they went and looked
at the 50 years of returns they had and
looked at what kinds of companies had
high
returns and what kinds of companies had
low returns he said what do you mean
what kinds they they looked at different
characteristics of companies for
instance they found two variables that
seem to explain difference in returns a
lot better than betas the first is your
market capitalization as a company small
companies earn much higher returns than
large companies and then they made that
leap of faith they said if small
companies earn higher returns they must
be
riskier they found that low price to
book stocks where market value of equity
is lower than the book value of equity
earned much higher returns and high
price to book
stocks again they concluded low price to
book ratio must be a
proxy they actually ended up with a
proxy risk model you tell me a market
cap and you tell me a price to book
ratio there's a regression equation
we'll plug it in there and we'll tell
you what your your expected return or
hurdle rate has to
be you've given up on measuring risk you
just saying I'm going to use proxy
models those proxy models have exploded
since then you know why because you a
lot more data if you keep looking at the
data you'll find more and more stuff
that explains returns it's called The
Factor zoo at this point because there
are so many different things that you
can throw in there and you've seen the
Super Bowl indicator right the AFC team
wins you could the stocks will be up the
NFC team wins stocks will be down so by
that's I guess a bad sign for this here
that the Eagles
won but those are the kinds of things
you throw because you're looking purely
at statistical significance what
improves the R
squ so let's see where we are now we
have all these different alternatives
Liv to the capam we have these proxy
models but if you go into any consulting
firm Bank company and you look at how
they compute the cost of equity guess
what's still being used you'll see the
beta it's like Freddy
Krueger keeps coming back right every
Halloween he's gone but the next
Halloween he comes back in Freddy
Krueger part 13 part 14 part
15 cap Bay is just hang
around and there's a reason I think they
hang around to beat a model you need a
better a better model the capm does a
bad job explaining returns 10 to 15% I
do think you can improve that if you
estimated beta better and I'm going to
talk about with but no that's a low
number but to beat it what do you need a
model that has a higher R
squar the Arbitrage pricing model
multifactor model have better R squares
if you look at past returns but when you
try to for has returns that falls away
so let me ask you a question if you're
going to get a you're going to end up
with a screwed up cost of equity and you
can get there with a model which is
simple with one beta and one factor or a
model that's complicated with five betas
and five factors which pathway will you
take you're going to end up with a
screwed up result anyway right take the
simpler model and the problem is right
now we still don't have models that do a
better job in forecasting returns bet
the the the multifactor models and
Arbitrage pricing model do a better job
in explaining past returns which is why
they've got a foothold in the business
of evaluating mutual fund managers
because you're looking at past returns
and in corporate finance where
everything is about the future the capm
hangs in there I'm not a capm purist I
will throw it away in a minute if I can
find something that works better but for
the moment I can see why people end up
holding on to it because it works at
least
as well as the next best model you know
most of the time when managers want to
not use vas you know what they want to
use
instead gut feeling you know what the r
squ between gut feeling and actual
returns is it's probably 0% or minus 15%
I'd rather take a bad model over your
gut feeling because all it does is
introduces some discipline into the
process but all of this is built on the
premise that your marginal investor is
Diversified right so I'm going to assume
you've picked a company because you told
me you
dead I want you to go take a look at the
top 17 stockholders you can either go to
Bloomberg and I gave you a way of
getting the top 17 you go to Yahoo
finance you can get the top 15 20 it's
not EAS it's not difficult to get if you
have a foreign company you might have to
go to Bloomberg it might be more
difficult but the data is there and
what's the question asking who are the
investors in my company you have a lot
of inst tional investors the default
should be this is a company where the
marginal investors is likely to be
Diversified if you have a lot of
individual investors in very little
institutional holding then you have to
ask some followup questions and maybe
you will conclude that your company even
though it's publicly traded is more like
a privately held business and later in
this class maybe three or four sessions
I'm going to talk about what to do with
those companies because the traditional
way of estimating risk breaks
down so any questions about risk and
return models because you know clearly
we went through that really quickly
because I'm not interested in deriving
these models I want you to think about
the intuition Behind These models and
it's pretty simple Diversified investor
no transactions cost we all end up
holding the same portfolio and the risk
we measure is risk against at
portfolio so let's talk about hurdle
rates let's talk about the inputs you
require for the cost of equity in the
capm the equation for expected return
becomes very simple I need three numbers
I need a risk- free
rate I need a
beta now that we've accept beta as a
measure of risk and I need an equity
risk premium and I'm going to come back
and give you the intuition behind it but
it's a number in the brackets used in
foundations Finance you know what I'm
talking about e RM minus RF you used to
over and over so I don't know what it is
just an equation I'm going to put some
Flesh and Bones on that number because
it is a number to me it is the most
critical number in understanding
equities as an asset class so of those
three inputs which should be the slam
dunk the easiest risk cre it I remember
when I did my MBA was a long long time
ago the two years of my MBA program you
know how much time I spent on the risk
free rate 2 minutes I was told to use
the US Treasury rate as the risk free
rate and we moved on shows you how
dollar
Centric my MBA program was 1979 through
81 and second how much Faith there was
that the US Treasury was default-free
those were bygone years but that's what
my RIS Cree was life isn't that simple
anymore so I'm going to start by
defining what I'm looking for in
something that's risk-free and I kind of
gave this away in that first step of my
risk and return models when something is
risk-free you need to know exactly what
you're going to make GE guaranteed there
are no surprises none so for something
to be risk- free it has to meet two
conditions first there can be no default
risk not even a tiny bit and second
there can be no reinvestment risk and I
talked a little bit about this with the
example of a 10-year bond with a
one-year time horizon or a 10year Time
Horizon with a one-year table they're
not matched up you buy a one-year table
you got a 10-e Time Horizon you got risk
because you don't know what you'll
invest in no default risk no
reinvestment interest let's take that to
the next level if you carry that through
then you have to find a default-free
bond with which expires at the time you
want so if you want a one-year risk free
rate you want to find a default free
bill or bond that expires on the day two
year and in fact you can't have any
coupons do you see why because you have
coupons they come every 6 months they
got to be reinvested at rates you don't
know you almost if you want to be a
purist have zero coupon default free
bonds where you're risk free rate is
going to be different for one year 2
years 3 years four years 5 years the
last thing I am is a purist this is not
where I want to spend my time so I'm
going to give you a pragmatic
solution in when when the old days when
Banks were managed as Banks the way they
were managed with idea called duration
matching what's duration matching if
you're a bank you have short-term loans
you have long-term loans and in a
perfect world you should match up each
loan with an asset with exactly the same
duration but that's a lot of work and
it's messy so what banks would do is
they take the duration of all of their
assets and and take a weighted average
duration of and and try to get the
weighted average is equal it worked
remarkably
well only silicon value bank had
remembered that simple principle we
wouldn't have Silicon Valley Bank going
under because that's a basic duration
mismatch that they had I'm going to to
borrow that Concept in corporate finance
much much of what we're going to do in
corporate finance is
longterm you're not going to be
analyzing too many three-month projects
even a tech companies maybe 3 to 5 years
10 years 20 years and if you're doing
valuation it goes into Infinity you want
really longterm the cash flows a long
term if I compute the duration of a
project by looking at the cash flows and
when they come in I'm going to get
durations of 7 8 9 10 15 years so I'm
going to find one default free bond with
roughly the same duration I'm going to
use it as my risk free rate for every
cash flow and accept it's not pure but
it's close
enough so I'm going to make life really
simple if you can find a default free
bond in whatever currency you're looking
at which is longterm and find out what
the rate on it now is now you got a risk
free rate so how difficult can that be
well it depends on the currency you're
working with so let's lay out the first
principle
of what currency you should get a risk
free rated it depends on what currency
you want to do your analysis and and
that's your
choice you might you might resp why is
it a choice if I have a US company don't
I have to do everything in US Dollars no
you can do a evaluation of project
analysis in RIS and pesos and rupes if
you choose to if you're a Russian
company you might say I don't want to
work with rubles I want to work in Euros
you can do so but once you make that
currency Choice the risk-free rate has
to be in that
currency so for a little bit of this
class I want to talk about getting that
rate in currencies where it's easier to
do and getting that rate in currencies
where it's more difficult to do I was
taught to use the government bond rate
as a risk
free so let's pause right there why do
we usually consider government bonds and
a local currency to be risk free what is
it that governments can do that you and
I cannot that makes them default free
are they incredibly efficient is that
why they default free no they have a
power that you and I don't which is
print money if you have a printer in
your basement you're printing money
don't let me know I don't want to be
part of that game hey but they can print
money which means you should never
default right your mortgage is coming
you go print some more money send it off
to the bank you're
done we'll see why that's not enough
there are governments that can print
money that choose not to print money and
actually default
but that's your argument for why to use
so if your Government Bond is defa free
and we'll use a very simplistic test of
that you can take the government bond
rate and make sure it's
longterm and use it as your risk free
rate if your government is has default
you got some work to
do let's say I gave you the Turkish L
Government Bond rate you know what it is
right now
26% is it risk- free
not even
close I'll have to do some cleaning up
so we'll talk about what to do that
about that cleaning up process by
cleaning up I have to take the default
risk out of the
26% so let's start
easy let's say I want to do an I don't
know how many of you pick us companies
and you choose to do your analysis in US
Dollars you want a US dollar risk free
rate right so what I said you wanted you
wanted a long-term default free
bond this is about as easy as it gets
right I was just checking out the Wall
Street Journal this morning as the
headlin is has the has the numbers on
the market and right there it says 10e
note it's
4.57% you done right see that was
easy but implicit there I'm making an
assumption when I use that 4.57% which
is the US government is default
free 15 years ago you know what my
defense for that would be I'm not an
expert on Sovereign risk but the a
ratings agencies out there claim to be
experts they assigned Sovereign ratings
to every
country ranging from it looks like a
corporate rating but a AAA Sovereign
rating is is essentially default free
and you go all the way down
today 15 years ago the US was AAA rated
by all three major ratings agencies S&P
Moody and
Fitch today there's only one agency
standing that still gives the US AAA
rating which
is Moody S&P and fit have lowered it
it's not to some some terrible rating
but it's double A Plus so what do they
see they see a whiff of defaulter and
can you blame them I mean how many times
in the last 15 years have we come to the
cliff where say maybe we will shut the
government down and not pay our our
obligations maybe we won't it's not a
great feature in a default free entity
to play that game and the market is
saying okay you're playing that game
we'll have to low you know assess that
as default risk but for the moment I'm
going to assume that the US is defaulty
holding on to Moody you're saying what
if Moody is low as the rating then I
have some work to do and we'll talk
about what the work will be so you're
doing your analysis in US dollars for
the moment use the 10-year bond rate get
down on your knees and hope and pray the
US Treasury doesn't default and move
on how many of you working with European
companies in Euros okay what what what
country is your European company in
France okay so you have a French company
and you're going to do an analysis
obviously not in French Franks anymore
you're going to do it in Euros you want
a risk- free rate in Euros does the
French government have a 10-e bond
denominate
eurs but so do 11 other governments all
of which issue 10year bonds and Euros
I'm going to show you what the numbers
look like in November of 2013 I'll give
you the update now I went and look
looking for a 10year Euro bond rate
because remember one of my companies is
Deutsche Bank and I want to do things in
in euros and I found 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 10 different governments issuing
bonds 10 year bonds and euros and the
rates are all
different don't do the averaging thing
this is not a good this is not the place
to do it right because that's your
natural instinct they're different let
me take the average rate can I take the
French
rate what what's the the challenge
you're going to face you take the what's
the problem with the French
rate and how do you know
that that's it right if the rate is
higher than the lowest rate that
difference is default is this is in 1999
French Franks and German these are all
in the same
currency so if I'm valuing a company
analyzing a company in Euros what should
my risk free rate be November of 2013
which of these rates would you use as
your risk free rate the German rate and
don't get too caught up in the German
you're using the German rate because
it's the lowest and through much of the
Euro's history that's been true but it's
getting awfully close because Germany
has its own host of Economic and budget
problems coming the Netherlands is
actually starting to get pretty close to
the so through the somewhere during the
semester now Constantine is getting a
little happy here are you Dutch no okay
you just want the Germans to go down
okay I get that
right but you you you have to use the
lowest rate and I want to make sure
everybody gets a rationale for why it's
the lowest rate at least there's a
chance of being default free the problem
when you adopt a common currency what's
a power you've lost once you adopt a
common
currency that printing of currency is no
longer completely under your control so
there are people who argue that even the
German Euro bond has a whiff of default
risk the European Central Bank actually
issues bonds but to use their rates
first they're not as heavily traded and
the rate is almost equal to the German
Euro bond rate so if you want to make
that the place you want to make your
last stand go ahead and use a European
Central Bank rate but that's your risk
cre currency as I said is a choice so
let's
suppose no no but remember so there are
three places we're going to need it
let's say you are a German company
looking at an Indian project what's a
currency that's going to be easiest to
work with for an Indian
project Indian repace right so in that
project you'll do your analysis in
rupees because all the numbers in rupees
the managers think in rupes you're going
to come up with a hurdle rate in rupees
that s same German company is looking at
a US project you're going to work in
dollars so the currency choice is going
to be a function of in Project analysis
where is the project if you're doing a
valuation it's probably where your fin
what currency your financials are in
Nestle might be a multinational that
gets only 3% of its revenues in
Switzerland but if all the financials
are in French Franks it's probably
easiest to work in French Franks it's a
pragmatic choice there's no Theory
reason it's where you know which one
will create the least work in terms of
having to do
conversions and if you do it right it
shouldn't matter and we'll talk about
why so that's the Euro let's move on to
the easy currencies what are the easy
currencies the currencies where I can at
least argue that they're default free
because they have AAA ratings and in
November of 2013 these were all of my
trip a a rated government some of which
are no longer
AAA and the government bond rate in
there and you can see risk free rates in
Japanese Yan was significantly lower
than risk free rates in Swiss frank
which in turn was much lower than the
risk free rate in Australian dollars but
they're all risk- free in those local
currencies I want you to First dispense
with this idea of a global risk- free
rate that's
nonsensical the minute you say risk-
free I'm always going to ask you in what
currency because risk-free rates go with
currencies
you ready for the difficult
currencies the difficult currencies
where I can no longer use the excuse of
Moody told me there was no default risk
right because then if something goes
wrong I blame
Moody the difficult currencies are
currencies where there is default risk
and the and what's glaring at you then
is a rating that indicates as default
risk let me back up ratings agencies
attach two ratings to every country a
local currency rating and a foreign
currency rating
you know what they measure the foreign
currency rating measures the default
risk that Moody sees in India if it
borrows money in dollars or Euros or
Japanese Yan the local currency rating
is the risk that Moody sees in India
when it borrows money in
rupees you'd expect the Lo the the
foreign currency rating to be worse than
the local currency because you can't
print Euros to pay off the
debt so I went and look you know so if
you go looking for rating and you see a
AA rating under local currency you're
probably going to do what you did in the
previous page in November of 2013 the
rating for India was baa3 not a
horrifically bad rating but not a you
know not Triple Eight so what's Moody's
telling me that even in the local
currency they see the possibility of
default risk so let's pause right that
why would a government default on a
local currency
board I'll give you an empirical fact
that you might have to wrestle with half
of all Sovereign defaults in the last 50
years have been on local currency
bonds these are governments that chose
not to print money and default inste so
why would a government not just print
the money and pay off the debt why would
it choose to default if you print money
you create you're between a rock and a
hard place right you're saying do I want
to print money not default and end up
with hyperinflation or do I want to
default and you know what Latin America
start us every everything about
Sovereign default look towards Latin
America they're Masters at this game
they've been playing it a long time they
found every conceivable way to
default and not
default and here's what we've learned I
went to Brazil to do my first valuation
seminar there in
1997 every question I was asked for two
days was about
inflation nobody cared about know
margins and growth you know how about
inflation about inflation and who can
blame them they'd come off
hyperinflation the early '90s where the
inflation rate had hit
55% 5,500 they had PTSD they just could
not deal with anything without thinking
about
inflation no entity in Brazil including
the Brazilian government could issue
long-term bonds and re you know and you
can see why right if you're an investor
you say I'm not buying R bonds I
remember what happened in
1992 the Brazilian government finally
got around to issuing Bonds in r in 2006
14 years after hyper that's how long it
took for the PTSD to
fade in contrast take Argentina in any
just World nobody should ever lend money
to Argentina ever again right it's a
company that just in this Century has
defaulted four
times it's a couple of weeks ago I got
an invitation to come to Argentina for a
conference of portfolio managers and I
think the title of those is Argentina is
back
again and you know what that conference
will be filled with portfolio managers
because somehow they've they' managed to
develop Amnesia this I've seen this
happen in this Century at least three or
four times go back again the fact that
he defaulted two years ago people seem
to
forget this might be purely
psychological but it turns out that it's
easier and quicker to come back from
default than it is to come from
hyperinflation so what do some
governments do say will default look at
Argentina they can come back we can come
back too which effectively means that if
you have a government bond rate in that
currency there is default risk in that
currency even though you can say they
can print money no what the market is
saying they might choose not to do that
so he's saying what if I have a currency
where there is default risk and I'm
what do I do it's very simple
algebra in November of 2013 the Indian
government 10year bond rate in rupees
was
8.82% I can't use that as mer create
remind me again why because there's
default risk in it right so if this were
an algebra problem what do you have to
do you have to figure out how much of
that 8.82% is because of default risk in
removal I'm going to try every year on
my web page I have this lookup table
where if you give me The Sovereign
rating for a country I'll tell you what
the default spread should be for that in
November of 2013 a baa3 rated country
would have a default spread of
2.25% finish the algebra problem the
government bond rate is
8.82% the default spread is 2.25% you
subtract that out you come up with the
risk-free rate of
6.57% I'm not using Government Bond rate
as my risk free rate because it's not
risk free I did the same thing with
Chinese Remi or you know youan risk free
rate of
4.3% default spread much smaller than
India because its rating is better but
still there is default spread in as
subra now do you see what I will have to
do if Moody
lowers the US rating to double help me
out Derek what what did I have to do get
a risk free rate in dollars
so I'd take the
4.57% or 58% that I see on the top of
the Wall Street Journal page I'd
subtract out the spread for a doublea
rated Bond the world is not going to end
for I mean you can't just say I've lost
a AAA rating nothing we can do from now
on it happened the in the UK 8 years ago
and analysts got paralyzed they said we
are no longer AAA rated we're going to
stop doing financial analysis will
become AAA rated again you probably
never do financial analysis for the rest
of your life
so it's not the end of the world you got
to clean up so that's your one one
choice is to stay local currency clean
up that Government Bond R but remember
what I said about currency being a
choice if you're doing your an if you
let's say you're looking at a Venezuelan
company anybody brave enough to pick a
Venezuelan company I'm glad you know
that the nightmares you will have you
won't sleep for the rest of the semester
and probably for the rest of your life
is you want a risk- free rate in
Venezuela and bolar do you really want
to go down that
path or if you're analyzing a Russian
company do want actually get your hands
or you know the problem with Russia is
the they they no longer rated the
ratings agencies all stopped their
ratings in 2022 there so if you're
looking at Russia Venezuela you're
saying I don't want to deal with rubles
or Bolivar I'm going to switch
currencies for a long time in Latin
America nobody worked in local
currencies everything did everybody did
everything in US Dollars it's a
confession of hey I don't know what to
do too much
inflation does it make your life easier
yes on getting a discard rate but guess
what if you choose to do everything in
US Dollars you've just shifted your
worry to a different number right
because now if your cash flows are in
realiz you got to convert them to
Dollars you got to come up with an
exchange rate and the inflation you're
running away from is going to show up
there inflation is like having an
elephant in your living room you can
cover it with a big blanket and act like
it's not there but every time it moves
you're going to
notice so when you're in a high
inflation environment there's no getting
around the fact that it's going to find
a way into your know give you pain along
the way but at least in a risk rates I'm
going to do everything in US
Dollars there's a third choice which is
take inflation entirely out of the
picture what does that mean when you
project out revenues on a project of
company you project out based on
constant dollar in other words you
assume you can't change prices because
inflation is not there and when you
discount those cash flows then you need
a real risk free
rate and we actually have a number right
now in markets we can use as a real risk
fre rate it's called the tips rate the
treasury bond which is inflation
protected the rate right now is about
2.25% So when you buy that Bond you're
locking in that rate so how do how it
works is if you buy that Bond and
inflation turns out to be 7% in 2025 God
help us if that happens but you're going
to get 2.25 plus 7 if inflation turns
out to be only 3% you get 5.25 inflation
drops to 1% you'll get three so the 2.25
is guaranteed it's a real risk fre rate
you I mean develop the versatility of
being able to work with different
currencies or work because even though
you might have a preferred way of doing
it the person across the table you're
working with you're negotiating with
might be thinking in a different
currency and you have to be able to
switch and you now have the mechanism
for doing
it so this default spread number becomes
a number that you have to come up with I
told you one way to get it take the
rating look up the default spread which
is what I did for India but there are
two other ways you can get default
spreads which in November of 2013 I did
not have for India but if you're doing
Brazil those two are still on the table
there are some governments like Brazil
much of Latin America this is true that
issued long-term government bonds
denominated in US
dollars so the start of
2025 the Brazilian government had a
10-year dollar denominated Government
Bond with a rate of
7.75% can I get a default spread from
that or do I need to compare that 7.75%
to get a default spread it's in
dollars if you assume the US Treasury is
default free the t-bond rate is a def is
a default free rate in dollars 4.58% at
the start this year 7.75 minus
4.58 is
3.17% that's a default spread for Brazil
it's a market set number in the bond
market the only problem with that
approach is there only about 15 to 20
governments that issue Bonds in either
bond in either dollars or Euros because
remember you can't compare a rupee bond
rate to a dollar B the currencies to be
matched up so until by 20 years ago it
worked for about 20 for 20 countries 20
years ago a market opened up called The
Sovereign CDs
Market anybody know what the Sovereign
CDs Market allows you to do you don't
have to give me a detailed description
but what does a sovereign CDs Market
allow you to
do let's say you buy buy a Brazilian
Bond you're worried about default right
you want to insure against default risk
you go to The Sovereign CDs Market you
can buy insurance how does the insurance
work remember the 7.75% you're getting
sovereign PDS spread for Brazil at the
start of this year was
3.23% so when you collect your 7.75%
from the Brazilian government you got to
send 3.23% of that to the
insurer say why would I want to do that
because Brazil actually
defaults at least in theory the insurer
will step in and make you whole again
it's a market set default spread and
it's driven by demand and supply and it
comes with all the Plus pluses and
minuses of it being a market set number
like what if there is something that's
happening on the ground right now The
Sovereign CDs spread will reflect it so
the day you know Syria has a sovereign
CDs spread the day things start to melt
down in s you saw the spread jump and
then it adjusted so you get this updated
number that reflects the world as it is
today so when Russia in invaded
Ukraine and I'm picking my words care
y not only the Russian spread and the
Ukrainian CDs spread Jump The Sovereign
CDs spreads for all of the East European
countries that were close by also jumped
it's an updated Market set number what's
the downside of using a sovereign CD
spread it's an updated Market set number
why because markets sometimes Panic they
sometimes taken there are Parts I think
people in this market who would have no
idea what countries in Latin America
where so there Latin America there so
Brazil gets into trouble they sell chile
and once what are you doing it's in
Latin America or they would take Asia
and make this whole continent be the be
the recipient of something happening it
is the way of the world and which means
that these spreads can be more volatile
but it's good to have it's in fact those
two numbers the Government Bond spreads
and the CDs spreads that I used to
create my lookup table cuz I find bonds
with a triple B rating and and look at
the spreads and take the average
and now for the rest of the world
because Sovereign CDs spreads are
available for about 80 countries for the
remaining countries I can use the lookup
table so one way the other these default
spreads and and it's not just for risk
free rates we're going to see these
numbers back when we talk about Equity
risk
premiums so November of
2013 risk-free rates were different in
different currencies these are all the
governments with default risk you're
saying how do I read this graph the the
height of the column is the government
bond rate the purple is the default
spread so if you look at the Pakistani
repeat the government bond rate was 15
point something perc but a big chunk of
it was default spread you took that out
got a risk free rate the winner if you
want to be a winner in this race in
terms of having the highest risk free
rate was
Brazil but there's a new winner in this
game if you update this graph this is as
of the start of this year and the clear
winner there's not even a close second
is the Turkish lra your risk-free rate
is
21% I want you to think about that if
your risk- free rate is 21% and you're
building on top of that what are your
hurdle rates going to look like really
really really big
numbers because inflation is pushing up
and in fact that's the main reason these
risk free rates vary it's not because
I've cleaned up for risk these are truly
risk-free there's only one thing left
that explains difference these r rates
which
differences in
inflation or expected inflation High
inflation currencies will have high risk
Rate rates I don't care what the central
banks that do how what dances they do
the risk free rate will be high low
inflation currencies will have low risk
free rates and deflationary currencies
could even
have negative risk fre rates we've
cracked the code to another question
that kept coming up in the last decade
how can rates become Negative they can
if you have enough deflation
and very low real
growth so when you think about risk free
rates as a general proposition you know
you can't just take the government bond
rate check it out but it's not rocket
science so as you look at your company
and a currency that might not be the Cur
you know US dollars or Euros it might
seem like extra work but it's not that
big a deal of cleaning up those
rats so let's talk about Equity risk
premiums what did I say the T bond rate
was this morning when I checked
4.57% or something you know the equity
risk premiums what you would charge over
and above that
number to invest in equities as a it has
nothing to do with your company it's
what you would CH so let's pause right
there you're getting something
guaranteed let's say the US Treasury is
guaranteed 4.5 and I'm trying to get you
to invest in something riskier first
would you charge
demand a higher number or a lower number
let's get this part of the if many of
you said lower then I think we should
pause perhaps stop the class because
it's kind of a loss cause you can see
why right if I guarantee you 4.57% I ask
you to do something riskier so I want a
higher
number so let's see what goes into that
right what makes that number a higher
lower
First Once you got the greater than zero
should it depend on risk conversion or
risk you are absolutely the more risk
averse you are and let's let's pause
right and think about what goes into
risk aversion can you tell me some of
the things that make might make you more
risk ofs than your neighbor what are
some of the things yes your age will do
it so let's pause right there are
younger people more risk averse than
older people or less risk averse less
risk averse and actually there's an
interesting implication if you have a
market of investors and the investors
are
aging what should happen to the risk
premum in that
market it should go up which means stock
prices should go down China and Japan
Japan already and China perhaps in the
future are facing a reckoning a
demographic bomb is going off that's
going to show up as higher risk premiums
so age
matters but even before you get to age
is some of this just you were born with
it are some of us born more Rovers than
others I have four kids I can tell you
which ones going to be in invested in
bonds for the rest of his life
preferably risk-free municipal bonds
maybe and the other one and I can tell
you which one's going to be in
options my oldest son is 35 he still
comes down the stairs holding on to the
banister I'm to fall right now fixed
income guy if you ever saw one right my
youngest son when he was three took off
from the top stair expecting to be
caught before he hit the bottom there's
an option
Trader so some of this you're born with
you can't fight it in fact I'm going to
give you a risk aversion next weekly
puzzle is actually going to be a fun
puzzle where you can test out how risk
averse you are give you a
score so your age
matters part of it is this is going to
be maybe a question I should be careful
about asking but I'm going to ask it
anyway does what sex you are matter you
know are men more risk averse than women
or vice versa what do you think because
there have been studies that have looked
at
this how many of you think women are
more Rovers than men
and that turns out to be true for young
women and I can attest to that I said I
told you have four kids only one of them
is female and that's the only person
whose car I would get into when they
were taking they were learning how to
drive let's face it the most dangerous
group on the face of the Earth in terms
of taking risks is young
men next time you go into a trading room
at Investment Bank look
around and then ask yourself why aren't
there more trading fiascos
happening I remember when Society
General all had this big trading Fiasco
with a know six billion in losses and
after that I wrote a post where I
suggest to investment Banks a very
simple
strategy for risk manag you're saying
make them
higher you can change your your make but
that takes a long time what's your only
force in the world that can take a 23 or
a 24 year old male and make him not take
stupid risks his
mother not even his father I mean father
you blow through so I said here's what
banks need to do you hire a Trader who's
24 hire his mother as well PIR a couple
of hundred thousand to sit behind the
trader saying what are you doing right
now that looks a little dangerous can
you pause right now and tell me what
you're doing hey that's a couple hundred
thousand but think of the billions you
might save in some trading law that's
not going to
happen risk aversion is hit by all these
different things which means that not
only is it going to vary across people
it's going to vary across time because
your risk aversion will change if you
lose your job or if you get
sick so we're going to start with a very
simple exercise where I want to find out
how risk ofers you are there's no right
answer don't look at your neighbor cuz
this is about you so let's say you're in
a market where you have your entire
wealth and you can specify a number for
it if you want to make it big make it
small whatever you want to it's entirely
invested in a guaranteed investment
making 3% a year I've quit my job and
I've become a salesperson for the
Vanguard 500 Index Fund so I want to be
very clear about what I'm selling you
because stocks is just too generic I
call you preferably during dinner
because I know you know that's when
people call and they say I here you've
got all your money
invested in risk-free or guaranteed
Investments making 3% so how do you know
I have my ways I've got you on the hook
because you think you've invaded your
privacy but then I offer you a deal I
said look would you be interested in
taking your money where from where it is
making 3% guaranteed and putting it into
the Vanguard 500
Index you can say no and shut it down
but if you think about it at some
expected you're going to be tempted
right so here's the question I'm going
to ask you how much would that expected
return have to
be how much would that expected return
have to be for you to make that switch
okay so I'm going to go down the numbers
3% guaranteed less than
3% okay good we got that out of the way
between three and
five okay is uh what's your name Chris
the most risk averse person in the room
or the least risk averse person in the
room
room he's the least risk averse person
in the
room doesn't make him a bad person so
don't dump on him he's the least RIS ofs
person in the room and his Equity risk
premium is about 0 to 2% right more than
so Equity risk is what you're charging
let's keep going between five and
seven okay so we're still in the less
risk ofe group but your risk PR is
between 2 and 4% how about seven and
nine okay N9 and and 11 so we're getting
towards a more risk ofse end how about
more than
11% nobody okay if this were the entire
Market we're done you know what I'd have
to do I'd have to take a weighted
average because each of you told me we
did Equity risk premium is I take a
weighted average of what you told me you
would demand you say weighted by what
not by how much enthusiasm you showed
when you put up your hand but by how
much money you have let me be brutally
honest if you have no money I don't care
what your risk freeing is you can
whisper it to me you can yell it to me
if you have $40 billion I'm really
interested what Warren Buffett thinks
about the equity risk premium right now
matters more than what the rest of us in
this room this building and probably the
entire neighborhood think because that's
what $40 billion brings to the table
this isn't a democracy it's a dollar
weight democracy and the equity risk PR
reflects
it but just to show you the number you
gave me is not set in stone what if I
told you you that in the hour you've
been sitting here the D the Dow dropped
9,000 points you know don't do anything
ration nothing has happened this a
hypothetical I'm just throwing that
little piece into the puzzle right so
you're exactly where you were a minute
ago when you gave me a number but now
I've added this little detail that the
market is down 20% if I asked you the
same question I asked just a minute ago
I just want a sense of direction you
gave me an equity risk premium how many
of you would demand a larger premium now
that I've kind of thrown this into the
mix why what what is it that happened in
the last minute that's made you more
risk ofs you got a reminder of what risk
really is about right not an abstraction
I could lose 20% of my money how many
would demand a smaller
premium and the argument would
be if stocks are cheap at 32,000 there
should be even cheaper at 26,000 right
it's a contrarian argument it's actually
easy in ually to do that but in practice
it's the most difficult thing in the
world right your hand will get Frozen as
you know I can't reach the keyboard no
it's it's terrifying but you can see
risk premiums can shift in both
directions I which direction it shifts
because what my basic point is equity
risk premiums are not just different
across people they're different across
time and that is the challenge we face
in estimating Equity risk PRS how do we
estimate a number that's Dynamic and
keep shifting over time so I'm going to
give you the three ways in which people
estimate equ brims I don't like the
first two I never use them but I'm going
to put them on the
table and I'm going to let you make your
choice but no when you make the choice I
want you to think through why whether
the choice they delivering on a premium
that actually reflects what's happening
out there the first is to do what I just
did with you survey people on what their
Equity risk premium is there have been
surveys of investors of CFO so I'll go
through the list of people surveyed and
why nobody uses those survey premiums
the second is to Look Backwards what
does that mean when I ask you what you
will make over and above the treasury
rate you look at the last 50 years the
last 100 years and you look at what
you'd have made and say that's what I'll
make in the future we'll see what the
embedded assumptions are there but that
is the default way in which most people
get Equity risk Brees it's backward
looking it's static but you have
discomfort up that's what I used to
make the Third approach is to get a
forward-looking dynamic premium and I'm
going to try to give you a way of
getting
there the upside is will be forward and
dynamic looking the downside is that
number will be different tomorrow and
the day after in fact today it changed
and we'll talk about why it changes more
on some days than others so let's start
with the survey approach survey approach
you have to pick a subset you can't ask
every investor out there there's too
many of them so all of these surveys
they pick a particular subgroup uh
Securities Industries associate which is
a trade group used to survey individual
investors and they stopped in 2004
because they found it pointless because
here's what they were getting if stocks
had gone up a lot the survey said
they'll go up a lot they' gone down a
lot so basically people not giving any
kind of sense of what the future would
bring they were just reflecting what had
happened in the recent past Mar Lynch
surveys portfolio
managers big institutional investors why
should they matter remember we talked
about waiting about how much money you
have what Black Rock thinks about the
equity risk should matter more and that
premium again has been kind of stagnant
because it looks like it's there's a lot
of inertia in it it's 4.8 goes to 4.9
4.7 not much change because I guess
institutional investors don't think that
seriously about Equity RM they so caught
up in what stocks over the next three
months Campbell Harvey and uh and John
Graham who teach a Duke do a survey FC
of
it's a very different audience right
where do CFOs use equity risk PRS to get
hurdle
rates and they've tracked that number
over time and that number also is pretty
stale it's more backward looking than
forward looking Pablo Fernandez does
this every year he's teaches at a
business school in Spain he he surveys
equity research analysts and he reports
a premium and he also surveys academics
one of the most useless groups to survey
in this context why what do you need to
affect the equity risk premium a lot of
money this is a poverty stricken group
what's the point of asking what's the
equity risk premum but I guess the
academics are the ones who put the
number into the textbooks and then they
get used elsewhere but the bottom line
is nobody uses his survey premium at
least INE equities there is an asset
class where survey premiums are actually
the state of the art that's how it's
real estate you know I know you're
familiar with kushman and Wakefield
right basically big real estate
Consulting SL asset kushman and
Wakefield surveys real estate developers
when they take properties as to what
their cap rate is which is the return
they're demanding on stocks versus so
they come up with these risk and then
other real estate developers use it and
for a long time it worked because you
had a small group of real estate
developers essentially setting rates and
they look to each other that's broken
down it's the largest real estate
investor in the country right now
it's not any of the developers it's
Black Rock right institutional investors
have come in even in real estate people
are not using survey premiums anymore so
let's set that to the side but you will
see this number kind of floating around
people do surveys this the number people
look at the number interesting but
you'll move on the second of course is
to look backwards and here's the process
very straightforward you look pick a
period of time 10 years 20 years 50
years in the US you can go back almost
150 years
Robert Schiller maintains a stock return
database for US Stocks going back to
1871 here choice you can go all the way
back and then you compute two numbers an
average return on what you'd have made
investing in stocks over the period
let's make up a number 9% and an average
return you'd have made investing in
something RIS fre treasury bonds
treasury bills let's say it's 5% 9 minus
5 is four you got an equity risk frame
it's called a historical risk frame
because comes from looking at the last
100 years and then you make a leap and
you say that's what my Equity risk
premium is going to be for the future
pause right there when you do that
you're making two assumptions right the
first
is it's called mean reversion what's
mean reversion you assume things will
revert back to the way they used to
be is that a safe assumption we use it
all the time we we get away with it it
works until it doesn't right I use this
example my valuation class I'll do it
again you know the San Francisco Giants
baseball team signed Justin
Verlander do I think twoe contract
legendary pitcher amazing pitcher was
one four sa Youngs lifetime RAF 2.3 has
won like 16 to 20
games if I asked you how many games will
Justin verando win this game and what is
the ra going to be mean reversion will
be you look at the past and you say he's
going to win about 16 to 20 games and
have erf 2.30 why isn't it going to
happen what am I missing in this
picture he's 40 right let's not use old
because it makes me feel even older he's
younger but he's 40 years old and 40
years for a picture when you've done
that
know it's been a structural break mean
reversion works until there's a break in
the structure you say I can't just
assume the past so you see what why
people got away using the historical
risk because this practice developed in
the US and then got exported to the rest
of the world you know why it works so
well in the 20th century in the US the
US was the most mean reverting economy
slm market of all time in the 20th
century it was like clockwork you had a
recession 6 months later this happens
one year later this happens you always
reverted back why because it was the
global
economy I I tell people look I was
willing to accept historic RIS until
2008 you what happened in 2008 well you
got some reminders first we got a
reminder that we were in the 21st
century took us eight years into the
century oh my God we're not in the 20th
century anymore we also got a reminder
that the global economy was not just the
US you all these other and we got a
reminder of how tied together we were
this a structural break I think it's
extremely dangerous to use a historical
risk premium in 2025 because what are
you assuming we'll go back to the way it
was in 1965 197 in what universe is that
even
possible but I'll show you what the
numbers look like because so many people
use every year on my web page I update
these historical risk premum I never use
them but I update them because you know
might as well put it out there it's not
rocket science this is public data I'm
not paying anybody for this the returns
are out there you gather them I'm going
to show you a table of the historical
Equity risk premiums for the US that I
get keyword is PL is premium it's not a
premium you're saying why are you
getting multiple premiums because first
it depends on what slice of History I
look at right I could go back 100 years
my data starts in 1928 that's roughly
100 years I could go back 50 years 10
years 25 years I'm going to get
different risk premiums then I said you
compare to something
risk-free I've compared it to both t-
bills and t-bonds T BS are shortterm 3
months 6 month e bonds are longterm 10
year I get different
premiums it even depends on how I
compute an average sounds weird but if I
have a 100 Years of returns one way to
compute the average is add all 100
numbers and divide by 100 simple average
but when you do that you're missing a
key part of how investing
Works which is it returns compound
sounds abstract but if you have a stock
that starts at 100 doubles in your one
and drops by 50% you're effectively
where you started but through the magic
of arithmetic averaging I can claim that
you made a 25% return plus 100% minus
50% a geometric average is a compounded
return you can see the numbers are all
over the place but every one of these
numbers is
crappy that's a financial term you can't
trust it we seem to forget statistics
when we wander into Finance Land If This
Were A statistics like not take a 100
numbers and give an average what do you
forced in a statistics class to put in
Brackets below that
number a standard
error a flag saying my estimate is five
but by the way my standard error is one
which means the true number could be
anywhere from 3 to 7 we abandon that
practice the minute we leave statistics
classes if I go back all the way to 1928
that's a long time right and I tell you
the equity risk premium is 5.44%
and the reason I'm going to go with t
bonds is remember when I talked about
risk free rates I said we're going to
look at long-term rates so tbls don't
matter and this number is going to go
into a discount rate that gets
compounded over time so I'm going to
stick with a compounded average if you
force me to pick a number on this table
I'm going to pick
5.44% and then I'm going to say look
before use this number truth and
advertising requires me to say that
5.44% comes with a standard of roughly
2% so play it out in your mind if this
was statistics class and I gave you the
standard err a number how do we use it
to get a
range you add or subtract two standard
errors right you add or subtract 2 * 2%
to 5.44% tell me what the equity risk PR
for the US could be going forward
somewhere between 1 and a half% and 10%
fat lot of good that does me but that's
with 100 years if you go to 50 or 10
years take a look at the standard
telling me what stocks have done over
the last 10 years is telling me
absolutely nothing it's like noise cuz
stock returns are so
noisy so I'm going to give you an
alternative I don't like survey PRS I've
never liked historical PRS are used to
use when I started but there was in 19
the 1980s starting in the my mid 90s I
said I'm not comfortable looking
backwards to get a premium for the
future I would like a forward-looking
number so to see what I'm going to do
I'm going to step back from what we're
doing and talk about something you must
have run into your foundation
class think about how you compute the
yield to maturity on a bond you take the
price of the bond you take the coupons
of the face value and what's yield to
maturity you remember from foundations
what's yeld to maturity on a bond
France a IR of the C which makes the
present value of the cash flows equal to
the price of the
B we do that all the time in fixed
income it's a forward-looking Dynamic
number because every time the bond price
goes down the yield to maturity will go
up bond price instead of the bond price
assume that you bought
stocks let's say you bought the S&P 500
you know what I what you're going to pay
is up front that's the S&P 500 what are
you going to get as cash flows not
coupons but dividends and BuyBacks those
numbers are not fixed they will change
over time so you got to estimate them
and unlike a bond which comes with a
finite maturity the end of 10 years you
get your face value back stocks keep
going and going a little trickier but I
can set it if I can set it up I should
be able to compute an internal rate of
return for stocks so I'm going to take
you back to November of 2013 then I'll
give you what the updated number looks
like today because I've done it this
I've estimated this number at the start
of every month starting September of
2008 before 2008 I used to do it once a
year and there's a story here as to why
I went from annual to monthly and I'll
tell you that story in November of 2013
there the index
1756 just pause right there do you know
what the S&P 500 is at right
now 6,000 you know what investors are
the most ungrateful Bunch on the face of
the Earth Market goes down 5% oh oh my
God the world is ended where did you
start mean Indian equities are having
their moment right now not a good moment
but a bad moment be amazed the bitching
and mourning about how stocks are down
15% hey take a look at the last decade
take a look at where you started and
where you are but I guess that's human
nature you look at what have you done
for me lately so 1756 that's what you
paid for
stocks dividends and BuyBacks I can't
tell you what they will be but they I
can tell you what they were in the 12
months leading in and in 20 2013 they
were about 82.35%
which are like 63 trillion so the index
units is you give me the number I'm
going to scale it down to whatever the
index is stated in terms of so you know
I've in terms of index units the
dividends and BuyBacks were 82 so I'm
almost there I have the level of the
index I have the cash flows from last
year what do I need expected cash flows
to the Future there is no way on God's
Good Earth that I'm sitting there
estimating these numbers for each of the
500 companies can you imagine doing that
at the start of every month it'll suck
up the whole month so I look outwards to
see if there's somebody who's making
estimates for future earnings for the
S&P
500 the S&P 500 is the most tracked and
followed index in the world there at
least a dozen analysts in New York whose
only job is to track the entire index
and estimate what the earnings for the
index will be in future periods Market
strategies this is all they
do so here's what I do I take analyst
estimates of earnings growth in the S&P
5 I know right now he's saying analyst
could be wrong they could be biased
we'll come back and address it of course
they can be wrong but whether they're
biased we have to deal with and I use
those analyst estimates to get expected
dividends and BuyBacks for the next five
years I took last year's dividend
applied the analyst growth rate at the
end of five years what happens well
these are the 500 largest market cap
stocks in the US they can't keep growing
at a rate higher than the economy so
after year five assume they will grow at
the same rate as the economy saying how
the heck do you know what that's going
to be I cheat and you're going to see me
use this sheet over and over again I set
it equal to the risk-free rate because
to me the risk-free rate is the best
proxy for nominal growth in the economy
I'm almost there I've got the level of
the index I've got the expected cash
flows after year five those cash flows
keep going forever all I don't have is
the r right it's a little messier than a
bond we can hit the YTM
button in Excel you got to use a solver
or gold sck for it but you know it's
it's pretty easy to use you have an
Excel spread sheet I get an expected
return of 8.04 let me pause right there
what does that tell me if you bought US
stocks at the start of November of 2013
un care what you hoped you would make
what you prayed you would make what you
told me you'd like to make given what
you paid for stocks you can make
8.04% the t- bond rate that day was
2.55% the difference is my implied
Equity risk premium on in November of
this week's uh in pra the tools where
the in practice webcast I'm going I'll
take you through this process and I'll
give you the Excel spreadsheet but
rather than make it a black box I want
you to own it to think about where you'd
get the numbers right but because in
November of 2013 I faced a choice I
could go with the historical premium
which in November of 2013 was 4.2% so
the table that I showed you through 2024
I didn't have that table in 2013 for
obvious reason
the historical premum that's what
everybody else was
using and I said that doesn't make sense
we're in a market that seems riskier
that's charging a higher price for risk
and if I want to come up with a hurdle
rate I want to reflect the market I'm in
this post 2008 market so from this point
on for all my November 2013 calculations
when you look for the equity risk PR for
the US you're not going to see 4.2%
you're going to see 5.5% roughly the
5.49% that I got as my BL pre
of course this opens up a question I can
play this game with us stocks right I
could do historical premiums I can do
implied premiums because I have a luxury
of data saying what do I do if I have to
get an equity risk premium for for a
market we don't have history
Vietnam
Cambodia even markets like India have
history but much of the history is
useless because reflects a very
different stock market you take a look
at the Indian Equity Market in the 1960s
and70s there were like 10 stocks that
traded very light liquidity so there's
not much historical data so at least I'd
like to frame how I'd come up with an
equity risk premium for those markets
you could in theory compute implied
Equity risk Prem to each of the markets
but the data you will you for those
indices for the sensex the buesa much
more difficult to get than the S&P 5 one
day I might be able to do implied PRS
for every Market but we're not there
yet so here's one solution it's very
simplistic take the US Equity risk PR
the 5 and a half% or the 4.2% whatever
you want to start as your base remember
the default spread we looked up to get a
risk free
rate just take add that default spread
on to the US PR this is how investment
Banks get Equity risk prams for other
countries this is so it's as simplistic
as this start with the US premium God
only knows where that came from added
default
spread and now that we have a sovereign
CDs Market you can use that spread if
you don't like the default spread you
get from ratings and you're done so here
for instance if you take 5.5% as your us
Equity risk which is what I get from the
implied premium there are the default
spreads for India China and Brazil
there's the equity risk
premium the one problem with this
approach is you're taking a default
spread for buying government bonds
issued by that government and you using
it as the additional Equity risk premium
right and that's always struck me as a
little dangerous why because equities
are riskier than bonds if you're
charging 2.25% for buying an Indian
Government Bond the extra amount I think
you charge more than that for buying
Indian
equities so here's the last step in the
analysis I take the the default spread
from the previous page and I said if I
can somehow estimate how much riskier
equities are than Bonds in this market I
can use that additional premium as my
extra country risk
premium so let's take it here
2.25% or the standard deviation of the
sensex was 24% so that captures the
equity index the standard deviation the
Indian Government Bond was 177% that's a
risk in the Government Bond again an
algebra problem for the 177% Government
Bond I'm charging a 2.25% spread I'm
buying Indian equities that spread has
to be
3.6% and I do this for India Brazil and
China next class we start I'm going to
start with that but I want to make sure
that you get both the intuition and the
mechanics of what we're doing I start
with the US premium and you have a
choice historical or implied then I look
up the risk of a country by looking at
the default spread then I adjust the
default spread for the fact that
equities are riskier than bonds so
please do pick a company if you haven't
get started Know download the annual
report the financials and if you can get
to a Bloomberg which you might not if
you're leaving now and you're going
somewhere else you know
get the things you need for your company
basically I'll send a list of things you
can pull up it take it'll take you about
five or 10 minutes on a Bloomberg
terminal to ask because I joined the
class after the first session my name is
not Onre sheet I'm to add
in I just want to confir thank
you e